[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi there i'm brian wood i'm the
technical communications and outreach
manager here at wolfram
i'm here with devendra capadia who's
part of the
calculus and algebra group and he's here
to talk about mathematics courses
at wolf from year so hello
hello brian very nice to talk with you
today likewise
uh so i understand we've got uh sort of
a little bit of a mix of things today
a little bit of old new and upcoming um
do you want to go ahead and just share
with us what it is
uh you've got going on in calculus and
algebra
sure so we have actually kind of got a
history of being
part of education we are the education
team in some sense
in the r d group um we do a lot of that
so let me just share my notebook with
you
uh what have been my thoughts which have
been putting together the last
couple of weeks because it's a great
opportunity for me to talk to people
about my
courses so basically we've been involved
developing a series of interactive
mathematics courses
at work from you and to take it
back to a few years ago we were
excellent in calculus always that's what
we are known for
historically um but a point came where
we didn't know exactly how well we were
doing compared to
current textbooks so we started a
project to actually benchmark those
problems we solved
6 000 of them in one summer and then we
didn't know what to do with them you
know today we come a long way
so that's the background we have had a
course in
calculus and then linear algebra and we
we are
deeply involved in bull from you which
is the hub
the main body that does all the
excellent
education work at wolfram so that's the
background to my courses
cool so uh when you when you're talking
about the you said you mentioned the ap
calculus course which i think is is the
first thing
we we wanted to touch on um so this
is a course that's aimed at high school
calculus students
is that correct yes very much so
i i say high school but it could very
well be a first year college and
depending upon which country you are in
it might even be some other level uh
people can do calculus literary at any
age but
that's the course i'm talking about it's
called introduction to calculus
and um this course broadly speaking
covers the ap
calculus a b syllabus there are two ap
calculus just to make things
confusing for everyone so uh ap colors a
b
is the kind of the the the shorter
course
and bc is the more advanced course but a
b is the one that
a lot of people do and that's enough
let's say if you want to do uh economics
at university then
ap calculus av is what you need uh but
it will cover things which
the standard you know fare of calculus
differentiation integration etc
but the nice thing is that we have
actually uh evolved an
interactive course with videos and
problem sessions just like if
you went to college you know your ta
would meet you uh
once a week or twice a week in a small
classroom and the professor would
lecture it in a very large classroom so
in a very small interactive atmosphere
you would learn how to solve problems
your interaction takes place because you
can copy and paste your code
from the course notebooks into the cloud
notebook which is supplied to you free
of charge and you can try everything as
you go along so i think that
this is the the calculus course that
we we have evolved and it's been i think
pretty successful
i keep on getting good feedback from far
places like nigeria
and india and china and
so uh i guess that's the background to
it
and uh i just want to add that when we
began the course
you know we first we were kind of
wondering whether we should have an exam
or not i don't personally
care much for exams i think they can
sometimes take away the fun from
learning but i was convinced later on
that no no if you
people do like them and so we've added a
final exam to this course
uh a typical ap calculus a b kind of uh
multiple choice final exam you take the
exam and then boom you get your score
back you can take it any number of times
every time you take it you get a
different uh set of questions so no two
students in a fifth
room of 50 students would get the same
test
so it's a large bank question we are
very proud of it
i worked on it with a student a local
student who came to me this
year early on and so that's the
background to the course and what's
happened to it since then
since we first you take a test it seems
it seems natural
uh to sort of add that to this course so
that sounds
sounds very cool um i vaguely remember
taking
ap calculus uh back in what 2004
2005 and uh i definitely would have
enjoyed having the
having the interactivity back then uh
because there are plenty of those
concepts that are
you know just difficult to kind of get a
grasp spawn just by writing them down
pen and paper and looking at solutions
and things like that so
yeah yeah i just want to add that you
know
i'm glad that you are one of those i
didn't do the ap myself but i think it's
a pretty
difficult challenging exam so we do what
we can we have provided video lesson
like i said but it's also full text if
you're the kind of person who likes to
study the full text
that's there for you as well and it
works really well so there are different
levels on which you can approach the
course
and we've tried our best to make it as
useful as possible
yeah it's nice you sort of get to decide
what depth you want to go into
things yes so
uh so what else is new what else have
you got going on
yeah so actually uh one thing that
happened was that uh
earlier stephen richmond decided that
you know we should have a series of
study groups for
our courses and so uh they convinced me
that
i should take some time off from my uh
regular
my regular duty is to develop code and
uh look after a team of around 11
12 people uh who developed features for
mathematica and the world from language
but then i took time after all that and
we actually had a calculus study group
um with quite a large audience from all
over the
world and uh people of all age groups i
would range from probably 15 16 to
i would guess 70 taking part in the
group and the what happens that we
met each day from 10 o'clock to 11
o'clock for an hour
and we would just talk about some of the
videos we'd watch them
talk about them have some poll questions
uh do some exercises uh take a weekly
quiz
and so it was just like being a regular
classroom but very very intense both for
me and for the participants
we covered essentially the whole of ap
calculus a b
about eighty percent of it in three
weeks uh and
uh around 100 people just made it
through everything and
they they really did ask good questions
one of them actually um
led us to give slight personal touch to
us you know one of them uh
told me that they sent me a notebook
which she had inherited from a mother
who was born in 1920 and for her whole
life this
uh student had been lady had been
wondering uh what
do all the symbols mean and her mother
prepared beautiful notes
it's just that her daughter who's now
herself quite
you know senior had never understood
what her mother was trying to do
and so when she saw those notes and
attend the course
she finally put two and two guys ah now
i understand what my mother is trying to
say all these years but those are the
most beautiful notes i've seen in my
life
and just for that i would say the study
group was worth it for me
wow yeah that's a really interesting
story so uh somebody sort of
bringing something from from earlier on
in their life back around to finally
get a better perspective on it that's uh
that's really cool
yeah the other thing was that we we kind
of we do want to reward people who come
to our courses again i i told you
earlier that i don't
particularly like uh exams but on the
other hand people do like to
be you know acknowledged for what they
have done so we gave certificates to
those who finished the course in the
sense of
writing all the video lessons and doing
the quiz etc
but i think that i i was stunned to see
if i use the word to see their sincerity
they're deep knowledge and there was
professors there were students there's
everyone in the room
just you know helping each other along
and that spirit of learning
is something that you cannot uh
replicate in the
course itself the online course so
there's a study group which is more kind
of active and
uh you know for everyone to interact and
then there's the
online course so people went back and
forth and many of them might have even
finished the whole online course
on their own yeah yeah and i think that
that uh extra
uh ability to interact with people is
especially valuable right now because
everybody is
doing the virtual thing and everyone
that's a little bit isolated so
uh the study group sounds like such a
great idea um
thank you so what uh is i understand
you've got
a newer course as well there's uh
linear algebra has just come out
recently so can you tell us a little bit
about that
sure so um linear algebra course
actually started a couple of years ago
uh the issue was this that what do
people really need to know in
the modern world i mean should they know
internal mathematics of course they need
no algebra and geometry the staple
high school courses but then what beyond
that should be calculus of course
calculus is very foundational and if you
know calculus
apart from any errors it's just worth
learning so why not do it but
the question is what's really useful in
today's world of data science and
you know computing and economics and
all kinds of things so what do people
need to know mathematically to
make it big in this world and we found
the answer was linear algebra in algebra
is
definitely rightfully simple simple
matrices etc you can learn them in
seventh grade eighth grade
whenever but it's so useful it's what
underlies i think even if you were to go
into a hospital take a ct scan
very likely there's some linear algebra
going on underneath it big companies
find it useful to have their own
libraries for doing linear algebra that
means that
linear algebra is important so and so we
said let's do a linear because
but i i wanted to keep the course really
simple and make it interesting by
putting
applications so there's
the course has got of course all the
standard topics but it also has
things like data compression how do you
take uh let's say a picture
and compress uh the memory of that into
a much smaller size
using linear algebra and of course
that's just a kind of you know gives an
idea of what happens in the real world
but i think it's dramatic how much the
world from language is
doing that if you look at a particular
textbook from any of them today
you'll find that they probably do three
by three or four by four matrices
we can do find by 500 in a flash so
uh sure you know i mean historically uh
the first calculations would take
at mit would take days or even weeks or
months and now they get done
instantly so i just want to convey the
flavor of the subject
and how powerful we are in this area as
well from language
yes and i can i can uh say personally
that uh
again having taken a linear algebra
course uh in my undergrad this uh
wolfram language makes it much easier to
get through a lot of those complex
uh large many variable problems
um and of course uh so so this is
something that is available right now um
can you
can you kind of just show us how
somebody might find these courses that
we're talking about definitely so i'll
quickly take you to the
website which has all the courses on it
so uh before going let me just say that
uh
the as a slide said over there uh there
is actually a daily study group
which uh for lineage which will come up
very soon
um and uh so this page over here
encapsulates what you need
you need to go to will from you type
involved from you into a browser or go
to the word from page and look forward
from you
and look for mathematics i think if you
pull down menu over here which will
actually get you to mathematics
and then look for the the mathematics
courses
and these are two that i'm talking about
today uh introduction to calculus which
i just spoke about
international linear algebra uh so here
just to give you a
feel for what the course is like is
uh just it's kind of a very very nice
layout very simple you can go and start
the free course immediately
but this is a complete lineage course
and like i said
for the calculus course we found the
study group helped people quite a lot
so we have a study group coming up very
soon
in october should be quite nice
and so you see where the study group
page onward from you which has got
system modeling starting very very soon
i mean we already just began actually
and then
a corvette course which i think is nice
and relevant
and then linear algebra is up in
october mid-october because we have the
conference over here
we're all getting uh working on that
right now we're just preparing our talks
a little panicking last minute
conferences you know
if i talk so but apart from that uh
we are we're looking forward to the
study group as a way to let people know
about
all these uh wonderful courses and uh
let them actually learn the things quite
uh
carefully so this is uh i think in terms
of
the website go to full from you look for
mathematics
look for the courses and you should find
them quite easily you might need to
register but apart from it's all
completely free
uh stephen wolfram has been very keen on
keeping these free for everyone
uh his dream is to have people learn uh
the world from language which he has put
his life
time into it and so i think it is all
working really well
and and just to reiterate uh these are
all open to anybody who wants to attend
it doesn't you don't have to be a
student you don't
have to be a professor or a professional
you can sort of
just be someone who's interested in the
topic and feel free to join and learn
whatever you can yes uh in fact we had
that
exactly that mix in the study group
professors professionals
parents students everyone was in the
course just
really enjoying themselves interacting
and
they'll be same for linear algebra and
to take it a step further in fact
some people are busy you know you might
miss a lesson because
a video uh because the study group has
got the same schedule as let's say your
own
uh schedule so what you do then is
there's a makeup session on friday where
we actually go through everything
i do a review uh people are a bit
nervous about the weekly quiz so i
give them all kinds of nice hints to
make sure that they actually pass
without much problem
and so the study group is very much like
high school or college
uh it's open to all universal
free and we are very accommodating for
all kinds of
time zones etc excellent uh so we're
just about
out of time here but uh i will say
anyone who has taken the same
math courses that i have we'll probably
know
what course you have coming up next uh
so go ahead and tell us a little bit
about that one sure
i'll just take a minute first one so
this one has just begun it looks
uh like you know we all excite to have
this differential equipment because this
is where my heart is okay i've spent
16 years from doing differential
equations so i'd like to show people
uh the differential equations approach
why a mathematical world from language
this course coming up it'll have all the
standard
staple solution techniques but lots of
real world applications we might even
have an
example to show something about the
pandemic
and how historically daniel bernoulli
argued that
if you have a vaccine you can fix these
pandemic problems eventually
so i think that this should be a great
cause for those who want to take it
awesome um and so that's planned for
early 2021 you say
well 2021 and these things take more
time than you always
i mean we like to polish things and put
them out but i think sometime in 2021
certainly if you're going to take the
course uh in
after mid 2020 it should be available to
you just watch out on the website i
always write a blog post
watch the blog post and you'll see that
it's available to you
all right well thanks a lot for uh
talking with us and uh hopefully we can
get a few more people coming to
study groups and uh everyone be on the
lookout for
a differential equations course coming
up thanks a lot devendra
thank you thank you brian
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you